[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time I'm Rhett and I'm
linked this week at the round table of
dim lighting we're exploring
detoxing trades
I had to do a a big a landing because
that's a heavy hopefully they
manipulated it in post heavy so it
sounded better
so yeah we got a list of toxic treats
we're going to go through them and um
you know be prepared you might feel a
little a little tingle in your in your
conscience that you have a little bit of
toxicity in your life and um I'm sure
we're going to feel a little bit of that
I'm not above a little toxicity but it's
one of these we wanted to do it in a fun
way yeah but it's also
using the word toxic in the way that
people use it now and then also using it
to describe a trait
um because we're old
it's funny to think about the fact that
there was a big portion of our life in
which this language did not apply like
people were these things but people
didn't talk about them right before the
internet and really before social media
people didn't talk about all these
things you didn't understand yourself or
other people I mean I'm sure some people
did but the average person didn't have
all these labels didn't have all these
ways of putting people into categories
and also like knowing oh my friend my
friend has these things I have these
things
um so this isn't because that's the case
and I and I don't I have never like
evaluated
these things uh
very deeply yeah me neither so I I
didn't even I could not even have begun
to make this list so we just got this
list but we're gonna do it we're not
just gonna go through and be like yeah I
have that you have that I have that
we're going to have some fun we're gonna
do a toxic trade a draft okay so at some
point we'll figure out it's like an NBA
draft yeah this is like when we do those
uh uh those Good Mythical More episodes
with Jordan from Sport and we have to
pick things that we want to put on a
baked potato or whatever
so we're gonna list out these toxic
traits and then uh we're gonna go back
and forth
and you have to pick the one that if you
were like building a character a
personality and you had to choose some
they're all bad you have to choose some
of them yeah but you want to choose the
ones that you can justify as being Ah
that's not really that bad and by the
way along the way we might say I think I
actually have that that's why it's not
that bad because I already deal with
that yeah we're going to kind of build
some personalities and then Jenna yes at
any point when we are considering uh a
trait
you have the power to steal that trait
we're going to give you the power of
stealing how many times well how many
are there total there's one two three
four five
six seven eight nine ten eleven twelve
thirteen fourteen fifteen sixteen
Seventeen eighteen nineteen twenty
twenty one good gosh so uh We're not
gonna make We're not gonna go through
we'll leave some on the table
what do you mean oh maybe we leave some
on the table but I'm saying uh no I'd
like I like to force ourselves to take
all of them okay we have to we have to
take all of them but Jenna has to take
let's see if if we each took 10 that
would leave one I'd rather take eight
and leave five
five Virginia yeah okay well let's take
nine three and leave three for Jenna
that way we're not gonna stick you with
too many toxic traits here that's okay
not all of my toxic traits are on this
list so I'm very aware of mine okay well
that's a good point that this is not an
exhaustive list because thinking that
you can bond with wild animals and make
them pets when you camp is also a toxic
trait
are you talking about the people on Tick
Tock that do that yeah
I read that I didn't even make that up
oh that's a oh people admit to that my
toxic trait is thinking that I can be
best friends with this fox but have you
seen when people do make best friends
with foxes I really like it like I saw a
guy in this I don't I do not endorse
them I do not recommend this but I have
seen people say I think specifically
with a red fox hey if you go up to a red
fox you can just start petting it and
it's just like there's a tick tock and
things on its back making weird fox
noises not a good idea but makes a great
tick tock
just touching baby birds in their nest
and it's you know what it's not I don't
I just guessed but I also say you gasp I
just gasped I think I didn't hear that I
think you can do it oh yeah
no you shouldn't do that but I think
it's I think it's a myth it's a myth
that you can't that the mama will
abandon them but you shouldn't touch
baby birds that's toxic that's toxic to
call things myths so that people will do
it we have a responsibility here read
through them okay Adam I didn't know
there were this many they're all pretty
self-explanatory so when until we uh
where'd you get these from
Jamie
okay all right so a medium article we'll
go happier human article in a science of
people article we'll go into the details
of these traits when we consider when we
pick them but for now let me just list
them jealousy
being judgmental
fubbing which is getting on your phone
is phone snubbing getting on your phone
when someone's talking to you when when
you're in when you're physically present
with someone and then you get on your
phone and you get on your phone oh God
manipulative
ignoring boundaries lacking
self-awareness perfectionism
toxic positivity
passive aggressive Ness I guess
arrogance
people pleasing
comparing yourself to others
anger issues
holding grudges
attention seeking I can't wait to
collect these for myself like Pokemon
victim mentality
instigating drama slash gossiping oh
hiding insults in humor
narcissism uh-oh inflexibility
and overly competitive
oh gosh okay whoever is the least toxic
between the two of us gets to go no we
won't do that who can spell toxic
backwards c-i-x-o-t you know who can
spell it incorrectly but convincingly
t-o-t-o-c-k-s-i-c-k
[Laughter]
I said t-o-c-k-s-i-c-k
toxic that's pretty good I get to go
first okay what did you say
uh I don't remember because you were
talking at the same time speaking about
the same time oh yeah we're doing our
green our green t-shirt day you know
where the little bit you could be here
in person you would see just how
different these greens are but on camera
they look exactly the same let's do a
poll to see whose shirt is better matter
of fact we are doing polls if you're
listening on Spotify
we have the capability to to make polls
and then you can respond and let us know
what you think about things and the best
replies get published to the episode so
other people can see what people are
thinking so it's yet another way you
know we got the voicemail 1-88 earbud
one you can use the hashtag earbiscuits
to contribute to the conversation and
now you can do this on Spotify respond
to a poll let us know and we will
associate
those best responses with the episode
permanently
permanently wow you become a permanent
attachment to the episode
so you're looking through the list
figuring out what you want okay
I got my first choice okay
again I'm choosing the thing that I
think is not that bad or uh I'm trying
to stick you with the worst things
sure
I'm going to start by drafting
toxic positivity okay I mean how bad can
that be you have to put the word toxic
in the description just so people will
understand that it's negative yeah what
describe get read the definition of this
uh so it's it's more of a description
this so I'll explain always looking on
the bright side can actually be harmful
sometimes people want to be sad and in
their emotions regardless of the
severity of a situation and always
trying to get people to be positive
diminishes and invalidates that person's
experience true so I don't disagree with
this and I think I probably
um I gotta I got a little bit of this in
me when it comes to dealing with other
people who are going through something I
never know exactly what to say to
someone who is having uh who's sad
and usually what I do is
I try to immediately help
right so it's just like well I'm sad
about this and I'm like well at least
you're not dead you know like
trying to get people to see the bright
side because that's how I cope with some
negative experiences that I have
sometimes I'm like well I'm having a bad
day but I could go on the internet and
find a lot of people having a lot worse
day than me and that I don't know if it
helps or not it's probably not healthy
but because I do that with myself
I try to do that with
most often I think I do this with Jesse
yeah and I do this with Christy as well
whereas she might want to
be sad be upset
and have someone be upset with her or
empathize with her and I'm like well I
mean it's not that bad consider this it
never never really works but I I think
I'm saying because I chose this one
first ah it's not that bad I mean you
can be that's not that toxic someone
who's always trying to get you to look
on the bright side I mean it's not that
bad
I mean it could be worse it could
definitely be worse see what I did there
me and Chrissy have this thing you know
there's certain points in your
relationship when one or both people
would be like I feel distant from you
and my wife's never told me that a lot
of times
I'll say that I I'll do that too I'll
minimize it'll be like I'll start
pointing to all the Practical reasons
it's not your fault it's not my fault
it's just the the circumstances we've
been tied up in this we've been busy
with this we've been all over the place
so yeah
when I what you just said helped me
realize that I just need to be like you
know what
I feel distant from you too and I hate
it
I hate it well that would be
manipulative
which is another toxic trick if you're
if you're just saying announce your
point where you can steal his toxic
positivity but it's kind of early
uh now it seems too easy it might be
manipulative you are being manipulative
right now but it's yours if you want it
I actually do think toxic positivity is
one of my toxic traits that I do
um and I've I have been working on it so
you don't need to steal it because you
already have it I already have it yeah
yeah it's already it's already mine okay
okay
I'm you know I'm seeing manipulative
stares me right into the face it seems
like if you're manipulative you get what
you want boy that would be nice
okay
first of all anything we say I just want
to give a disclaimer anything that I say
um
just kind of like making making not only
light but
um talking about a toxic trait is as if
it's appealing
just you know don't wig out about it
it's not that big of a deal right Rhett
you have it help me out here uh yeah
that's right link uh it's just part of
the game here don't take anything out of
context he's so pleasing I definitely
don't want anger issues like who who's
gonna get stuck with that one
um
oh gosh this is obvious I've got to take
attention seeking um I gotta take it I
mean
you know uh somebody's somebody's got to
take the attention and I'm willing to do
that a lot of people don't like
attention so if I enter you know it's
like I'll take one for the team I'll
take the attention so that you don't
have to worry about it you know it's I'm
helping these this this maybe the
socially anxious in any particular
situation look at me
kind of the hero for doing that
well you're also I mean is there anyone
in this business
who's not attention seeking especially
guys who have been doing it for their
entire adult lives and and people aren't
tired of doing it
yeah you know what I'm saying like it
never gets old entertainment is by
definition attention seeking and some
people are like I'm really good at this
thing but I actually don't like when
people watch well we would be lying if
we we want people to watch we're
constantly like we have whole
departments at mythical who we have
people whose job it is to get people to
pay attention to us like not only are we
working to get you to pay attention to
us we are paying people to get you to be
interested in us yeah like we are
attention [__]
you can clip that out and put it on Tick
Tock that's why I said it with that
that's why I said [__] because I
thought that would be a good way to end
a tick tock but what do I say in the
tick tie well nothing
unless this is still part of it so say
something cool real quick
it's a horse real loud
hors d'oeuvres oh you screwed it up
um always needing to have the attention
on them having main character syndrome
is another form they always have a
better story of got a better job or had
a worse time depending on the situation
and they really can't fathom that other
people should have the attention or that
everyone's motives don't somehow involve
them ew
well if you put it that way it doesn't
quite it doesn't quite have the ring a
ding dong that it did they're all bad
they're all bad I'm just trying to I'm
saying that you can justify why this one
is somewhat better than the others and I
should have read this first and then
ended on my my rescuing the socially
anxious uh from getting attention later
on attention defers yeah I don't think
it's about taking the attention off of
people to help them well I'm that's the
best I can make of it well that's mine
well what I'll say is that have it where
I think that this can be positive
is um
it's often entertaining that's why
people who are in entertainment
but then it can obviously the reason it
gets toxic is just like when the
attention seeking in the like main
character syndrome permeates every
aspect of life and every in interaction
yeah like nobody can get it there's no
camera on us right now and we're still
trying to be
[__] derbs
okay a little snack Jenna you want to
take that one I don't I don't like that
one no I don't want that one okay okay
okay okay okay okay okay okay I get it
right as your go again I'm going to take
I think this is going to be triggering
because uh maybe it's because I just I
don't relate to this and I this is so
not me that it seems
I'm gonna take ignoring boundaries
lots of people talk about boundaries and
I think boundaries are great
um maybe it's because
I don't have a sense of it that much
with my own
boundaries and I don't feel like I'm a
boundary Crosser
maybe that's why it doesn't seem that
bad to me but disrespecting
boundaries is a major red flag whether
there's someone you recently met or have
known all your life setting personal
boundaries is perfectly acceptable as
they help build respectful and
meaningful relationships however
boundary Crashers continue to cross the
lines established to guide their
behavior toward you and loved ones now I
think maybe another reason I think
there's I'm going to take there's I'm
really interested that you chose this
one because this one is gross because
this one is not like with attention
seeking it's like okay yeah it's
annoying
this chap makes it all about himself and
you know but wait boundaries is is
really about getting in getting into you
know it's like getting in somebody
else's it really impacts the other
person directly it's like getting in
there getting all in their mess Let me
let me contextualize this okay so again
I think one of the reasons that I don't
uh quite grasp the serious seriousness
of this is because
I am I never do this I don't ever
I probably don't get personal and
vulnerable as much as I should sometimes
and so maybe I just don't I just don't
have much of a barometer for this but
I'm thinking about like
if Jesse meets somebody
and I and I come to the and I come into
the conversation
four minutes after she has begun a
conversation with somebody there is a 70
chance that she has already told them
the significant life story stuff
uh
uh like we might be seven minutes in and
she's talking about like her former life
as an Evangelical Christian in her
deconstruction or whatever and and it's
interesting because she's such a like
disarming person that people are like I
love that like people who get to know
her like she's telling me everything is
so interesting and then this person
opens up and says this stuff that you
just typically wouldn't say to somebody
that you just met and I think some
people would say that
that's crossing a boundary I don't do
that
I don't think it would be Crossing more
of her own the person who's sharing but
it's over sharing so I guess maybe
you're saying it's more of like if you
get asking intrusive questions or like
getting in somebody's business like if
I'm like giving unsolicited advice or an
opinion yeah and I don't do that maybe I
should maybe I should try to get Jenna
to take this one
what is your understanding of ignoring
boundaries because I'm thinking about
like
people talk about
like parents like if you are an adult
child right and your parents don't
respect your boundaries like that's a
big problem yeah because they're they're
trying to parent you
yeah I would think of that but then it's
also like
um I see it as boundaries that are
clearly established like I've have
friends who don't like hugs they're not
affectionate and I'm one of those people
who is but they have voiced that they
are not so then that's a thing to me of
like oh they have told me that this is a
boundary that they have I will be
respectful of it and like I don't hug
them unless I like ask or say hey I
really need a hug right now could you
give me a hug and then it is on them of
like if they want to
cross their boundary to then help me
with my thing yeah don't don't go to
somebody's underwear drawer you know
what I'm saying yeah yeah I don't I
don't want someone to do what if they
don't know
what if they never know
I'm just I'm kind of afraid you took
this one not understanding anything
about it and now I'm afraid that like
you're really gonna right now see cause
damage my lack of well I don't actually
have to take this one with me for the
rest of you
we have to do this until the next year's
drought this is an annual thing my
ignorance don't exhibit these and prove
it my ignorance of uh ignoring
boundaries caused me to make this my
second toxic trait and I'm immediately
regretful
um
I'm going to take lacking self-awareness
because I already have it a lot of times
right and I just feel like
it I know it can well let me read it
first those who lack this trait
for those who like this trait those who
aren't self-aware can be the source of
constant drama primarily because they're
unable to see and take accountability
for negative traits that hurt other
people
I think this I think you made a mistake
bro being self-aware can be difficult
for some individuals but techniques such
as mindfulness can help
I
the thing about being clueless of
something
is it's more forgivable it isn't it
doesn't have this like heart of Deceit
it has this heart of haplessness
and I think that
you know it's
maybe you're it's like you could still
say well his heart's in the right place
he's just clueless
and so I'm gonna Overlook it so I I
think that I think that that helps a
little bit it doesn't seem like the
worst of them so it's like well it's not
pre-planned like yeah it's not sinister
right but would you rather somebody be
not self-aware about their
halitosis
or
their
um
tendency to
always
going back to the attention seeking
thing always as soon as you tell a story
before you finish the story before you
you know asking somebody something
and then when you begin to answer it
they just start talking about the thing
that they were thinking when they asked
you the question right that's something
that some people do yeah and that's
something that if you're not self-aware
of that
like that you know I'm saying like so
there's self-awareness lack of
self-awareness combined with another
toxic trait is like a lethal combination
yeah yeah so I yeah it it really Powers
it up so like yeah definitely so it
depends on what else you do the one two
punch of attention seeking and lack of
self-awareness you've done yourself is
wow what a clown yeah I I will be
stealing this one
yeah okay I would love to lack a little
bit of self-awareness I think I am a
little too self-aware and I sometimes it
is very exhausting and being a little
less self-aware sounds really nice
okay I I totally get that it's almost
like a little bit of weaponized
incompetence I would like to not
weaponizing competence I would like to
just not have to do nobody
I mean I I think that
yeah I I think I think you can get there
Jenna because I think I used to be very
self-aware I'm a lot less self-aware
than I used to be okay so it's possible
for me yeah it's possible you can you
can definitely get there
it's it's just like um I mean is it a
zero [__] given kind of a thing I mean
how many [__] given are you how many
[__] are you giving right now I think
hold on this is it 10 out of ten I'm
gonna interject here
equating lack of self-awareness with how
many [__] you give is a that's a that's
incorrect okay
because like the subtle art of not
giving a [__] that book which I read and
forgot about but I mean you get it all
in the middle you just did it all the
time you didn't really care about it it
was self-explanatory it was kind of like
okay yeah everybody knows this but no
one really does it
um I guess like
okay not caring what people think about
you right
is different than not being aware of who
you are right and because you know like
not caring about what people think about
you if in the positive side of that is
obviously like you're not trying to
please people and you kind of like
you're unabashedly yourself
etc etc
but then if you are not self-aware and
your actions like some other toxic trait
are negatively affecting someone then
you're relying on someone else who cares
enough to point something out to you
which is really tough for people to do
because most people are kind of like I
uh it's hard I don't want to have this
conversation like I don't want to have
an uncomfortable conversation I don't
want to confront this person it's easier
to kind of just deal with it or just
kind of spend less time with them
whatever unless it's on a podcast and
that gets pretty entertaining so I I
think that this is a there's a fine line
here well a fine line I lost it so now I
have to choose another one
ear biscus is brought to you by
betterhelp you know everybody including
me faces situations where you don't know
exactly how to proceed and I think
traditionally what I would do is I might
talk to a friend about those things I
might sit there and think about them for
for a second or you may do nothing right
A lot of times yeah but I have found
that one of the benefits of therapy is
as I am talking about the way that I
feel or the challenges that I'm having
and encountering a particular situation
a lot of times the answer will reveal
itself maybe it might be a little
something that the therapist says but
often it's just the process of being in
that environment
will reveal the answer I agree whether
you're dealing with decisions around
career relationships or anything else
therapy helps you stay connected to what
you really want while you navigate life
so you can move forward with confidence
and excitement we love therapy and we
want everyone to be able to have access
to it no matter where you are what your
situation is if you're thinking of
starting therapy give better help a try
it's entirely online it's designed to be
convenient flexible and suited to your
schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapists
anytime for no additional charge let
therapy be your map with better help
visit betterhelp.com ear today to get 10
off your first month that's betterhelp
help help.com ear ear biscuits is
supported by chime you know having a
little extra money in your pocket can
help you spruce up your life a little
bit call it fold money you know that's
what that's what my granddad caught got
a little folding money
and that was pre-digital age well a
little extra money helps everybody live
their best lives and chimes online
checking account is here to help you
live yours with chimes online checking
account you can enjoy lots of perks like
fee free overdrafts up to 200 you can
even get paid up to two days early with
direct deposit no more pesky overdraft
fees and no impact on your credit score
to apply chime also has no monthly
minimum balance or overdraft fees with
access to up to 60 000 fee-free ATMs
which is more than the top three
National Banks combined and can be
easily found on the chime app plus you
can send and receive money with friends
through chime regardless of what bank
they use and cash out your money fee
free your credit's a big deal so build
yours up with chime just open a chime
checking account with a 200 plus
qualified direct deposit to get started
and you can get started at chime.com ear
that's chime.com ear the chime credit
Builder Visa credit card is issued by
stride Bank NA member FDA I see time
checking account and 200 qualifying
direct deposit required to apply out of
network ATM withdrawal fees May apply on
time payment history may have a positive
impact on your credit score late payment
May negatively impact your credit score
results May Vary
I'm definitely see and you Jenny you've
helped me here because I've been drawn
to the ones that I identify with and
what I need to be doing is the opposite
yeah you gotta do what I'm doing he's
like oh I love it I just haven't been
myself aware I haven't been self-aware
enough to do that so now I'm gonna like
so I definitely am not going to choose
perfectionism
and
um
I'm definitely not going to choose
oh gosh this is tough hiding insults and
humor it's like I'm I can I can already
pull that out of the holster
I don't want that one because I already
have it
man do I have all of these what why am I
trying to go and overly competitive here
we go
the last one on the list friendly
competition is fun and healthy
okay but when it gets to the point of
intense anger they start to make life a
competition always having to one-up you
might get a little nasty to get there
whether it's talking you down
whether it's talking you down to other
people to look better
maybe I should just say whether it's
talking down to other people to look
better or belittling your
accomplishments it can be tiring to be
in a race you never intended to start so
I'm yeah as I've firmly established why
don't we just turn it out
into me convincing you that you're
actually competitive that'd be fun I
let's do that I mean
I want to be able to rise to the
challenge and totally say you know what
I can win this I can beat everyone at
this and I'm fully committed and I and I
believe and I care so much that I'm
actually getting I'm getting hated about
it and I'm oh gosh I'm so into it and uh
you know Sports and um uh measurements
and oh what do you mean about
measurements
well you know typically a lot of times
when you compete there's like a
measurement involved are you talking
about that when we play like which is
shorter like a credit card or a lighter
is that what you're talking about oh
yeah yeah I mean we're like great game
by the way well I was thinking more like
shot put but yeah oh oh oh measuring the
performance of something okay how far
your shot put one went yeah okay because
I just want you know if I just want
everybody's shot to be put
but no look at my put being shot
and this is where it gets see this is
the whole podcast oh boy I wish I could
delete it
um but we don't do that
uh is I conflated because I still
conflate the two
attention seeking and competitiveness
that was a thing that I did not ever
articulate is I was paying hey we both
seek attention and you were saying I'm
not competitive and so if competition is
wanting to perform at a task better than
someone else and that's the strict
definition
then that I guess is a different thing
and in my mind I'm like well but the
reason that an athlete wants to win the
gold medal is because what do you get to
do at the end of the gold medal ceremony
you stand at the top of the podium you
know the center of attention there's
Myriad reasons we compete
I do it to feel the anger
your turn
um
huh
I'm gonna take this big again because I
do already have it and I actually don't
think it's that bad for anyone else
other than me people pleasing
um he's taking people pleasing
it's like how can you get mad at
somebody for pleasing other people now
obviously it can be a bit torturous for
the person who's doing it yeah you're
really taking one for the team uh but
no one
um
most people
if they had to choose like okay you have
to hang out with this person and this
person is going to be a challenger or a
people pleaser and be like what's going
to be the easier afternoon well somebody
who's going to be a people you're going
to be liked yeah because you're going to
be like hey I'll go I'll do this or I'll
do that and I think sometimes I get a
little bit um
uh I get a little bit conf maybe there's
some confusion about this and I think
I'm a people pleaser because I'm pretty
flexible and I'm kind of like I really
honestly I don't care where we eat
because I really love food and I'm
probably going to have a great time
regardless of the choice that we make
and so it's not that I'm trying to be
like this deferential person it's just
that I genuinely don't care and what I
find is that I run into a lot of people
who do care and I'm like okay
if you care why don't your opinion wins
out here but then there's also and I
think we both kind of run into this
problem before where it can get
um
not necessarily I guess it is somewhat
toxic but
when you just won't tell someone
what you think when they actually need
to hear it
because
you're like I don't wanna I don't wanna
ruffle fat I don't want to upset them
like we've always been we've we've
talked about it you're gonna suffer
you're gonna suffer from this well no
one else is we've I think we we have
both suffered and now you're saying as a
unit long term other people will suffer
well I think that we've seen you're not
telling them as a uh we've talked about
this quite a bit and I think we've
gotten better at this but like as a
we're as a business unit yeah as an
entertainment entity
we're really easy to work with I mean
listen we know enough people in this
damn business to know that most people
who are entertainers for a living like
the relationships that they have with
their agents or their managers or their
attorneys or their employees or whatever
or can be much more fraught than than
ours are because we've seen it a bunch
right
but there's been a number of times
when I'm like oh man sometimes when
somebody really stands up for themselves
really defends their perspective really
holds the line on something and is not
worried that this is going to be
upsetting or offensive to someone who
wants something from them yeah I've
actually seen that benefit the person in
a way that was healthy
and I think we've gotten better at that
just through trial and error and
experience yeah we got more sir but
personally
I think that
more often than not but I'm trying to
defend this because I'm taking it what
I'm saying is that offended
if you're building a character of a
person in this per and the idea is that
this person is supposed to be the least
toxic of the two people at the end of
this when we compare these toxic traits
I think that people pleasing is is a low
score and ultimate toxicity but you're
gonna end up holding resentments against
everyone for taking advantage of the
fact that you're a people pleaser yeah
but I'll hold it in keep it to myself
and you'll feel guilty when you do say
no
yeah I do and when you can't please
everyone you're gonna break down well I
haven't broken down yet
thank you red thank you for I feel like
you can please a lot it pleases me a
long time that you have chose a
breakdown Jenna you don't want this one
do you I already have it I don't want it
no thank you
it is playing a different game I'm
playing a different game yeah yeah I'm
like I'm like give me give me the toxic
Trace I don't have yes I wonder what
that feels like
where am I gonna go now
it's getting tougher you know well yeah
because they're getting real bad yeah
they're getting bad they're getting bad
well there's a there's still there's
enough I'm gonna go with arrogance okay
I'm taking arrogance for the win
because this is a competition now
confidence is one thing but arrogance
means you think you are superior to
everyone around you no one could
possibly match up to your awesomeness
and you make it known
I
you know I I would like
maybe it's maybe it's weird to hear me
say this I would like more confidence I
to me it comes down to this there's this
one aspect this is very specific so this
is this is where I'm going with this
if I get accused of something
I immediately am like oh I'm I'm sorry
you the default is the accuser must be
right it's just a disposition I have
like I just have this
and I don't know what it's related to if
it's my perfectionism that I just have
this Keen sense of falling short of the
ideal
in any given situation that if I get
accused of something
I'm like oh gosh you caught me and I
didn't even know it you know I didn't
mean to do it but you're right and
um
I I think that that can't be true all
the time you know 100 of the time that
somebody levels something I mean it
can't be true or it can't be 100 true
and I think that's just how that's just
how I react and I would like to have a
little more fortitude and confidence in
that particular area
um I would hope that no one would ever
accuse me of being
arrogant
um
so maybe I need a little bit of that in
my life for for once it'd be like
you're wrong I'm right because I'm great
and you're not oh we're both great both
great you're great I'm great we're both
great so I have it and I actually feel
pretty good about it you know it was a
great choice for me it was pretty
arrogant Choice good to be kind of kind
of arrogant uh
is
why because I I am not arrogant you're
not arrogant no I'm visiting
self-deprecating
I would like a little arrogance I I
think
um uh
I think I would like to know how that
feels to just think of them yeah yeah do
a little
do a little strut and uh you know I'm a
hot [__] what does that feel like you
want it like a peacock yeah you want to
pick a hot [__] day of the month
or where I can be hot [__] can we put it
on the calendar and you just know that
that day I come in and I'm just like
well it might need to be a weekend but
yeah okay
not during working hours first of all
can I take issue with the whole hot [__]
thing like hot [__] is not a great thing
like if I came into the office you took
off hot [__]
in the bullpen area
that would be like what people wouldn't
be like look at that hot [__]
it'd be like I mean the hotter the [__]
the more the more stinkiest got yeah
what about hard and crusty [__] well
that's way better it's impenetrable you
can pick it up you can throw it
I just find it interesting that the [__]
became positive but that's what we're
doing today by the way I don't think
arrogance is positive I don't think hot
[__] is positive but it arrogance gives
hot [__] vibes
if it makes sense
so
we can we're relating to this
aspirationally in the specifics that I
gave can you relate to that or is it
different for you like if you get
accused of something is your knee-jerk
reaction to be like uh you must be right
my knee-jerk reaction is
um disappointment and shame yeah so yeah
yes that's right that's pretty much it
yeah yeah yeah yeah we can I would love
to be like you're wrong
we can have it well maybe we have a hot
[__] day a double hot [__] day
culturally we kind of like
um that's an interesting take on it the
being corrected and standing up for
yourself
but I think that there's like we kind of
reward
um think about the most like badass
celebrities right they're sort of like
and I'm talking about like
singers performers like think of okay
let's see Prince Prince yes Prince like
he's he's well he's a lot of things but
like okay he's mysterious but don't you
feel like if if you were like if you're
confident if you watch end up in like
certain interviews
and you didn't know anything about him
you didn't have like a full appreciation
for him or whatever you'd be like that
guy's arrogant like the way he acted in
that situation or the way he acts on
stage like
but then I think there's something
I don't know what it is culturally where
we're like
he can do it because he's that good
don't you think that that something that
ends up happening is that we excuse
people's arrogance because they're
giving us something that's such a high
level and I'm not saying it's good I'm
just saying that like I think that
culturally we kind of
reward arrogance well I think we reward
arrogance in our politicians and our
entertainers
I think it's toxic
but I'm just saying that that's what I
think I think if you're confident to the
point of being a jerk and it has a
negative impact on other people that's
the line you don't want to cross but
Jenna has to now yes yeah I also think
it's um to add to what you were saying
read about rewarding arrogance I think
there's a nice thing to point out that
like we tend to reward it in men
yeah and like right women who are
successful and they give off hot [__]
arrogant Vibes and they're usually
vilified that's true and I also think
that uh is rewarded from a from afar you
know what I'm saying like I don't know
through a screen I don't know Prince
he's a badass yeah
um but then it's just like well what is
it like to be friends's but Prince's
buddy
I don't know that might be different and
I'm not singling like Prince I I quite
like Prince I don't know what he's like
what he was like interpersonally but I
think that I I think I've heard really
good things yeah but and also he's a
performer it's a persona but I'm just
pointing out the fact that we might be
like oh I like people love politicians
who are like badasses and like think
great things about themselves and put
other people down and are really quick
at like insulting other people right I
mean yeah we've had a couple of
presidents like that right uh more than
a few and uh not too not pretty recently
one that was sort of the embodiment of
arrogance and like people love that some
people love that but then you're like
yeah but what if it was your dad or what
if it was your best friend it would
probably be hell right and so I think
it's like relational and culturally kind
of two different things I gotta pick
another one yeah
take a replacement I'm gonna pick being
judgmental
um okay being judgmental is you know is
kind of like being
extremely discerning
right I mean you can be right about
something but be a jerk
you're not wrong Walter you're just an
[__]
kind of a thing when someone gives their
unsolicited opinion yeah but I say have
you read this yet on something and
Frames it as being brutally honest you
know a little tough love a little brutal
brutal honesty is better than
um
just just lying
wimpy line uh maybe sometimes I don't
know I'm trying my best not always
I
I am you know when you're a
perfectionist you come across as
judgmental and so I'm back in my trap of
like just trying to own what I am and
make the best of it which makes me seem
I like a jerk but um these are tough now
y'all just come on help me out here
so yeah that's my positive spin on it
because I've got it I've got yeah you
know I'm I'm Discerning there's a
there's a wisdom that's wielded that's
it's an unwieldy wisdom hmm
a Mal wielded wisdom
he's not wrong
it's funny like you're thinking about
the reaction Joe he's not wrong like
that's the first thing people are
thinking
if you give your unsolicited opinion to
something
I mean that hurt but he's not wrong
okay are you done
obviously uh uh I'm gonna take I keep
digging a hole I'm gonna take
perfectionism
all right take it because again I my
strategy here take it I'm a fan of it
but take it uh my strategy here is to
assemble
because I'm a people pleaser is to
assemble the person that somebody would
want to hang out with so
um
perfectionism this is yeah this is not
uh
uh I don't really know I I'm trying let
me read it first needing everything to
be perfect and uh
to one set of Standards can be
overwhelming for all those around them
not only can it be hard on others
perfectionists are too hard on
themselves and can really destroy
self-esteem and work-life balance
um
to me there's like two strains of this
right
because there is uh the thing that I
don't have
which you've clearly established that
you do have is if you take an individual
uh thing
or experience or something and just like
having an idea of the way that it should
go and the way that it should be to the
point where when it doesn't reach that
state it's like difficult right crushing
whatever
I don't have that
that's not my experience in
perfectionism but the like I'm a I'm a
workaholic and I'm like
um doing a bunch of things all the time
really really wanting them to be good
and spending a bunch of time thinking
about how that I can make them as good
as I possibly can and then feeling
attaching my value my personal value to
how good the thing that I'm making is
yeah so I do experience it in that way
and but because I think that it's
actually mostly it's an internal
struggle like I don't think
like if you have an employee who's a
perfectionist you're like yeah I've got
an employee who's a perfectionist or
like this person's a perfectionist now
it might become see what you're doing
here it might be difficult to you're
trying to not you're trying to not
impede on anybody else with your
toxicity
I'm saying that really take it you're
absorbing a lot here this can be an
asset for someone in a relationship a
perfectionist now it could become like
if the person yes it can if the person
is like
constantly down on themselves and
becomes like a [__] an eel not a good
point for that you should have said
Eeyore oh
if somebody becomes an e horror
like that's probably I think that
probably is a legitimate profession
um
a really sad cam girl
I think some people are into that yeah
it's like a manga thing Different
Strokes uh
I think that that can be really
difficult in a relational context if
it's happening all the time
but like I like I don't suffer because
of your perfectionism
do you know what I'm saying like I don't
suffer because of it
so I I'm glad to hear that I think it's
difficult for a person who's suffering
from it but again so far I'm just just
so you know I'm a toxic positive person
who ignores boundaries while pleasing
people and being a perfectionist I'm a
pretty good guy so far you're an
attention-seeking [__]
who's overly competitive and is being as
judgmental I mean if you still gotta add
one
well Jenna just lacks self-awareness in
his arrogance Jenna keeps taking my best
one yes I'm sorry you keep you keep
picking the ones I want I already know
the next one I already know my final one
okay so you guys just gonna have to wait
until that comes right okay
now they're about to get bad so
everything it goes south real fast
I just don't want anger issues
I don't want to hold grudges
victim mentality oh I'm really against
that
instigating drama and gossiping I gotta
take that one
because it just I mean it just sounds
like it could be fun
a little bit
a little bit maybe
it's hard not to get sucked into a
little bit of drama but when it's
happening all the time and your life is
full of it it makes you exhausting to be
around you either thrive on negativity
or subconsciously are addicted to chaos
I could get a lot of views I could
really Channel this into you know into
into some content
yeah I wouldn't be the first and I
wouldn't be the last
I don't watch that stuff I just I don't
get into it I don't get into it
but
might be fun what about uh what about
when somebody has the T on something
about someone that you know or you used
to know that's interesting like you
don't find yourself like
oh tell me more about that I I no I
really don't because I have that I have
that I'm not an instigator I didn't I
least dramatic person that you know but
what I do like is if somebody starts
talking some [__] about somebody I'm
like okay let me hear you know like I I
just like I admit I like reality TV I
like to listen to it yeah I like to
listen to it I I I'm just but I do not
participate I'm really far from this
because I think that
like oh gosh I don't want to get in
trouble here but like oh do it even when
someone is like
ramping up to being canceled and uh I
don't know anything about it like I'm
just I just don't I'm not informed about
anything rising up somebody tells me
something that's like somebody's getting
canceled and I'm like
my instinct is to take
that person's side because I and I think
it's and that's without knowing any
details I will be very clear
I don't take up for people who are being
canceled hmm
but I have this instinct to do that
because I feel like I could be next
totally accidentally well you could I
just feel like um
I
I don't know I I I to a fault I I like
to believe that I like to give people
the benefit of the doubt
and I thought you were gonna try to make
myself
sound good
here you're probably not I know I think
it I'm probably not yeah but that is an
instinct of mine like that's the side I
air on I'm like well you know there's
two sides of every story and like
everybody screws up and nobody's perfect
I passed a
um a sign for a church
and it said I love church said the name
of the church and then underneath it it
said Chill Vibes
no perf I'm getting choked up Chill
Vibes no Perfect People
cool La Church Chill Vibes Chill Vibes
no Perfect People
um it was a it was a thing in the middle
but I can't remember what it was and
[Laughter]
um so yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna be that
I'm gonna I'm gonna beat what did I just
pick instigating drama and gossiping
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
ear biscus is supported by Rosetta Stone
there's plenty of reasons to learn a new
language that's not the language that
you currently know I mean maybe you want
to travel and you want to be able to
interact with people maybe you want to
date somebody who doesn't speak your
language that could be fun that's for
real but you can't I mean communication
is kind of key
um so Rosetta Stone can help yes Rosetta
Stone is the most trusted language
learning program available on desktop or
as an app and it truly immerses you in
the language you want to learn so you
can learn Spanish French Italian German
Korean Japanese Dutch Arabic polish oh
my gosh look at this list and I I'm
thinking maybe I want to really learn
French this time so that I can go to
France I don't want to date anybody who
speaks French well you have a basis you
have a basis three years in the market
of Harnett County uh French right so
maybe you know you can build on that
base so I would be excited to learn
French but you can use it for so many
different languages the ones that I've
listed and they have used trusted
experts for 30 years with millions of
users and 25 languages offered and it's
great for fast language acquisition
Rosetta Stone immerses you in many ways
there are no English translations so you
really learn to speak listen and think
in that language which is designed for
long-term attention with its speech
recognition the built-in true accent
feature gives you feedback on your
pronunciation kind of like having a
personal trainer for your accent and not
to mention how convenient it is with
desktop and app options with audio
companion and ability to download
lessons offline and the amazing value a
lifetime membership has all 25 languages
for any and all trips and language needs
in your life it's a 299 dollar program
but with our code you can get it for
just a hundred and forty nine dollars
don't put off learning that language
there's no better time than right now to
get started for a very limited time you
can get Rosetta Stone's lifetime
membership for 50 off that's 149 dollars
for unlimited access to 25 language
courses for the rest of your life redeem
your 50 off at rosettastone.com ear
today
that's far from me so I can move towards
it okay I'm going to take Jenna didn't
take that one that's not the one she
wanted
I hate this one I hate you for this it
says like in your face disrespect man
I'm talking to you and you're just gonna
oh no I'm on my phone
uh it's a pet peeve
yeah
I think
I don't know I feel like this is a gen Z
thing that I I'm anticipating yeah a
cultural shift here
and I think again my kids do it and my
wife does it I get offended when I'm
watching a show with people and I look
over in there on the phone it's not
they're not even talking to me they're
just not completely committed like I'm
with you but I'm just saying that I'm a
I'm a one truck I can't multitask so for
me I'm a two screen guy I'm a no I'm
assuming that most people
I'm I'm projecting and then I get
offended all shows any show I only look
on my phone when I'm watching the show
if I'm bored with the show
if I don't care about the show
I think it depends on the genre
reality TV man I'm on my phone I don't
watch that except for Survivor and when
they get to Tribal Council I get on my
phone because that's the part I get I'm
just like well
really Tribal Council is the has to
where it really starts happening
well I don't know I don't watch Survivor
I haven't watched it in many years but
um I'll perk up if it's good I think
that while I do I don't I do think this
is toxic I don't think it's necessarily
healthy
but I think that if you're good at it
and I'm saying I think I could be good
at this like I'm listening to you yeah
yeah yeah
because I think I can do that if you say
something to me and I'm on my phone I'm
like yeah yeah and I'll repeat it back
to you I was listening to you I agree
this this is a safe Choice
the pet peeve area it's not like
um break off the Friendship it's and I
don't think it's so I think that's the
definition of toxic like if somebody has
this toxic trait and it has an impact on
you that's grounds to break the
relationship oh yeah yeah I think that's
my definition of what makes something
toxic so even though I hate this I don't
think this should be on the list and
that's why I should I should have chosen
it it's on my list I should have chosen
it oh gosh is is more of a strategic
Chooser on this list because I need that
mm-hmm
are you adding things to the list
because now every time I look down I've
seen something new
there's just 21 of these so it's like we
gotta kind of you know yeah let's let's
speed this up
jealousy manipulative passive aggressive
comparing yourself to others
I you're gonna if I don't choose
comparing yourself to others you're
obviously going to choose it
of course I'm just going to choose that
one the next thing that's not that bad
right
that's what I was gonna do so I'm
choosing compare yourself welcome to the
game welcome to the game we're competing
at that I'm currently winning
when you're constantly comparing
yourself to other people around you so
much so that it impacts your self-esteem
and you become either bitter or arrogant
um yeah I you know you could actually
come out on top compared yourself to
others I didn't think about that so
there you go win-win I'm already
arrogant I might as well get there by
comparing myself to you you're not
arrogant though because I took it yeah
this is as close as I can get
uh again you do you want that one no I
don't good so I mean this is another one
that is uh is pretty much on you
you'll suffer right again you might
become I got you an unbearable person if
you are constantly dealing with all
these internal struggles but like okay
this person's comparing themselves to me
right now they could be doing worse I
will say this is not I don't dabble in
this that often it's it's not to the
point that it's really ever been a
problem
habitually
so I could use a little bit of it
okay excuse uh
uh man boy
I don't wanna I mean inflexibility is so
opposite of my personality I'm gonna
have a real tough time taking that
um you know it'll help you move the
needle
for this next year
oh man
you know what
this is a big one
but I'm gonna go out on a limb and I'm
gonna take passive aggressive okay okay
uh so again everybody knows what this is
but I'll read someone who cannot assert
their needs and will make Angry remarks
but not be direct in bringing up an
issue they let things Bubble Up and then
act out in passive ways like making
Petty remarks sighing stonewalling
Etc they want the people around them to
be mind readers and tend to have issues
with conflict
uh so
I think
the reason I'm choosing this is because
you can fly under the radar I think that
almost everyone
at some point
does something passive aggressive I
think that this is like a universal
human value because
there are things that you want or things
that you feel and it's often easier
regardless of disposition and
personality to
say something that is hiding is cloaking
a real feeling but it's kind of a smart
assholy remark or or sometimes it's just
slightly harsh
and I just think that this is why you're
being passive aggressive you're being
passive aggressive is something that is
said in relationships friendships
and so I just think that everyone's
dealing with this a little bit
so I'm willing to take it because it's
not something that's going to be like
this downfall of a person it's just
something that everyone has a touch of
it
and you want to minimize it it's the
more palatable version of manipulative
so why don't you just take manipulation
because I don't because I'm not going to
take it
because I spelled Tick Tock or sick sick
talk what did I tell toxic toxic what
we're talking about I spelled toxic like
Tick Tock
um
holding grudges is such
oh man that takes years off your life I
just can't do that to myself
I can't take that one for the team
points is bad for other people too by
the way oh it's bad for which one that's
a pretty bad one externally
I you know what I'm gonna go with the
more amped up version of comparing
yourself to others and I'm gonna take
jealousy okay because it's still an
implied compliment
right it's like people who have your
best interests at heart are usually
happy when good things happen to you
you're not jealous of you so it's it is
it's very self-centered but it still
gives credit what credits do
okay
I'm taking this is a good time to bring
up something that a lot of people
pointed out when we did the
top 10 people that were jealous of
episode yeah everyone was like guys
you actually should have used Envy
instead of jealousy that's why we wore a
green shirts today
um
so
I don't know somebody has something you
want and we were talking about people
who had done things or had things
achieved things that we want whereas
jealousy uh is more like okay jealousy
is being this is just some
website uh is being fiercely protective
of one's rights position or possessions
characterized by feelings of fear anger
resentment and insecurity right so when
you're when your significant other is
having a better time with somebody else
you're jealous because you want to
that's you said that's that that belongs
to you versus if your friend gets
married and you're jealous because you
want to be married you're envious
because you want to be married you're
not jealous
and also like if you can't even say it
if you're jealous in a relationship
uh you're protective of it if like oh
somebody's some dude at the grocery
store whistled at you let me let me add
him
yeah don't don't go to the grocery store
anymore don't go to the grocery store
right you know but if you live closer to
the good Ralphs then I'm envious
um
exactly yeah let's make this about
Ralphs
by the grocery store all right pick
I'm not trying to be manipulative but it
is on the board
up for grabs manipulative anger issues
holding grudges victim mentality hiding
insults and humor narcissism and
inflexibility
um they're getting they're getting tough
to take but I'm going to take hiding
insults in humor because at least it's
funny okay
yeah
um
it says bagging on your friends in a
lighthearted way can be totally fine and
show closeness you don't do this but
when you're constantly making jokes at
other people's expense it can get
tiresome and it's basically bullying
hiding in joke form I I do this I
actually want more of this yeah I think
you could give a good ribbing
occasionally like I'd like I'd like to
see you give a good ribbing to somebody
uh like I don't
um you do it well you do it to me for
comedy but only in performance mode like
privately I I don't know if you ever do
it like I do it
I do it as a form of endearment like I
actually think that it's like a gentle
ribbing
is uh you know for your foreign a gentle
ribbon is for your pleasure that's
that's how I feel about it and I don't
disagree
I think that it's when it
um
well first of all it has to do with the
recipient a lot of times because I have
people that I know
uh
uh who like to do this sort of like
playful making fun of people you do it
yes I know people who do it more than
you
and I know other people in my life that
if they get together it's inevitable
what's gonna happen is this person's
gonna do their thing where they sort of
find these these soft spots and make fun
of you push your butt this person who's
sensitive and defensive gets really mad
and I've seen it a number of times and I
tend to be like if somebody starts doing
it to me I'm kind of like
yeah yeah okay all right when is this
going to be over but I mean I try to do
it about something that I feel is
innocuous
but you never know what somebody's
self-conscious about
right but because it is funny for
everybody else if it's funny for
everybody else
you know one person is suffering so if
you have to pick something I'll take it
let's just jam through these I'm taking
that one
from you yes why I
um I think I need a little bit of this
not neces because like I
I don't think of things in insulting
ways like I don't
it's hard I'm too I'm very nice and and
sometimes I've been in situations where
people have said mean things and my
retort is oh
and I don't say anything and I just
really wish I had like a I had the like
the kind of the the streak to be like
well I'm gonna say something mean but
it's gonna be funny as hell like right
and it's like you're gonna say something
mean to me I got I got something way
better singer and and I that's why you
wish you had that button where you could
rewind a little bit yeah I got you this
time it's like what because like I've
totally been in that situation where
I've some a stranger
um I've been polite to and just been
like no thank you and they say something
mean and that I would love to be like
well you I'm gonna be mean back now but
I can't I don't do that yeah you need
like a generic go-to but like your
mother right but that's such a I can't
yeah it's not good it's not good it's
not good one either yeah do you you um
you do you kiss your mama with that
mouth is kind of
maybe that's more specific could that
work no usually I feel like the only
time I did something that that I was
proud of was that when someone insulted
me and I was just like
oh you're sad
oh that yeah that's good that's good I
like that but like oh you're sad oh
you're sad that's it is it okay that is
it but you have to say it the way Jenna
said it oh you're sad oh God yeah yeah I
got a tear in mind wow wow so I've
chosen myself
it's a free-for-all now yeah no okay I
gotta choose another one I'm trying to
choose between
um
inflexibility and
what anger issues
um I don't have any inflexibility I
don't I mean I think on the Spectrum I'm
pretty I'm pretty flexible
so I'm really I I take a lot of pride in
my flexibility
so it's really hard to imagine me taking
on inflexibility that would be tough but
I'm pretty flexible so I'll take it I
see what I did there see what I did
I'm gonna take in flexibility because
you know what the the positive side of
this well let me read it because it'll
sound real bad when I read it because
that's how all these are when someone
just cannot have things any other way
than how they see fit they are terrible
at compromise won't go out of their
comfort zone and will pout if they have
to change a plan from what they wanted
um
this is really difficult to deal with uh
but the positive side of it it is if you
are very flexible and you kind of don't
care about a lot of things having an
inflexible person
sometimes you can reposition it as this
person just is planning things or this
person if I just step out of the way
this person will just do these things
and I might benefit from it uh so that's
the positive side so I think there can
be a positive side to it okay I'm going
to take holding grudges because
I think I'm
I don't think I've struggled with this
I think I'm pretty good at like moving
on I like I like relationships to be
intact I like to I like to get over
conflict
as quickly as possible like immediately
if I could so I could probably use a
little holding holding a grudge so hey
remember some people actually are toxic
yeah and you need to keep your walls up
and when they prove themselves as that
and show themselves as that you need to
Build That Wall yeah sorry to use the
term
did not mean to do that but
um yes I actually feel really good about
this yeah you've actually made that
sound good because I feel man I could
use some of that too sometimes there's
somebody who uh you're supposed to have
a problem with you know and then you're
like what if I run into them and then I
think to myself well I'd probably just
be like hey you know like yeah because
I'm a people pleaser and then but then I
also sort of like search to my heart and
I'm kind of like well I'm not that mad
at him right yeah yeah yeah yeah so you
wish you would have had it the reason I
didn't can't take it here's the reason I
didn't take it because it can eat away I
know some folk
who are Grudge holders and it makes a
lot it makes other it makes certain
relationships difficult because it's
like I can't talk to this person now
because you got a problem with them
because of this thing that happened oh
yeah then they make other people have to
choose sides yes and so that's why I
didn't choose it because it makes it an
imposition for me sometimes to use the
parlance of parlance Jenna it's sad
because that's gonna be the name of
Jenna's podcast the parlance of Jenna
the the I like that the
it like when you hold a grudge it puts a
part of your life on pause
you know it's I mean I I just think
about like family members who don't talk
to each other it takes work it takes
work but it kind it it freezes an area
of your life
and that's that's a youth thing not even
a them thing
juice I'm gonna take anger issues
uh uh good I did not want that
um let me read it
we all get angry but when you're quick
to anger
it can be really easy to redirect it at
someone completely innocent having
issues expressing your anger in healthy
ways can lead to people getting tired of
hearing apologies later on and
constantly walking on eggshells around
you
um
the positive side of anger
uh well anger is a is a sometimes it's a
mask for sadness right that's one of the
things that I think that's what I
learned in therapy
hurt people hurt people
um and so if you get angry about
something there's probably a deeper
emotion under that that you need that
you should have just gone through and
and gotten to and also
um having anger issues is one thing
taking the anger out on others is
another thing they now have those rooms
that you can go to with a sledgehammer
and pay like
you know thirty dollars for an hour to
just bust up some televisions and stuff
the thing I don't like about you know
that means that it it kind of it bumps
up against violence
so well I'm glad you chose it didn't no
uh it didn't say it didn't say that it
said lots of people who are angry and
then don't do anything violent
but some do and that could be you right
well no that's not me I'm not I'm not
choosing violent anger violent Outburst
is was one of that was one of them
neither one of us would want to take
that just you know ain't just being
angry
oh gosh not that bad so I gotta choose
two of the last three yeah
manipulative or victim mentality
so you're you're not going to choose
narcissism
um
I'm gonna choose
manipulative because
um
my heart's in the right place I'm just
trying to get you there
I'm trying to get you to the right
answer
because I'm an arrogant perfectionist
well no you're not I'm mixing things up
here I'm mixing my real life with my
toxic character but
you know I you can be manipulative but
for good reasons right
um
you really need to wear that life vest
okay that's a great example
manipulative people
manipulative yeah
that's because they discuss themselves
as nice
to gain your trust before revealing they
are truly manipulators typically Target
and prey on the vulnerabilities of
compassionate and empathetic people
okay I did my best I think the reason
you can choose this one is because
to me it's kind of like passive
aggressiveness and that is
lots of times in a conversation somebody
might say you're being manipulative
right now everybody can fall into it
yeah you just don't want to be described
as a manipulative person which I do
think is what you just did because it is
like one of the main descriptors of your
person so we'll see I got to choose
between victim mentality and narcissism
this feels pretty easy
uh
yeah but so I'll take victims I I I
might surprise you here right
no I don't know
I was gonna try to find a way to make
because listen this town has a lot of
narcissists and as we have established
I think when we took the narcissism test
on the show many years ago
that there is a uh
there's a score
where if you're above a certain number
you're probably a narcissist right
but if you're and then if you're in
another score you have narcissistic
Tendencies but if you're in the middle
range or a little bit above the middle
range you're probably an Entertainer for
a living and then if you're really low
you probably hate attention right and so
I think that narcissistic tendencies
that are not like toxic level can end up
you know they can be a good thing
sometimes
but I don't know man people like it's so
it's so common these days to be like
that person's a narcissist and it's like
once you give somebody that label
it is like the worst ever so I'm going
to give it to you take it no
no I'm gonna take victim mentality
this person is always a victim everyone
is against them they don't deserve
anything the reason I was so reluctant
to take this is because I just hate this
mentality I just hate it so much I don't
want I don't want to have to put this on
my character
uh but you got to uh and if if they've
done something wrong they somehow turn
it around and are still the victim
oh I just don't like that but I'm gonna
take it so read them out what are you
and what am I hold on you you have to
make narcissism okay because it's yours
um
make it sound okay
I know
attention Seekers manipulators
gaslighters and Trauma bonders shall not
inherit the kingdom of God they only
think about themselves they cannot take
responsibility for their own actions
because they truly don't think they've
done anything wrong and confronted on
something they'll be completely
defensive lie and turn the situation
around they also dump all of their
issues on you and make you feel bad if
you don't have time for them because
they're going through some uh this makes
people's life this alone encompasses so
many bad things you can't make this good
man I tried to make it good a second ago
just say you agree with what I said
you'll take that I agree with what you
say
um I mean I'm stuck with it I'm not
going to defend it okay we'll start with
Jenna uh who is who at the end of the
day lacks self-awareness is arrogant and
loves to hide her insults and humor
okay that's how bad she is yes yes I
would like to I would like to have a day
of knowing how of being this yes but you
wouldn't know it because you wouldn't
have any self-awareness yes
hold on yeah that's hot [__] day yeah
hot [__] day it's you don't have to keep
Saturday or Sunday dinner it's all very
toxic but I feel like it's so opposite
me though just like oh what would that
okay I would think I'd be wearing like a
really nice like suit maybe a top hat
and a top hat oh yeah you're definitely
in a business suit oh I'm in a business
oh yes all right okay what are you uh I
have toxic positivity I ignore
boundaries I'm a people pleaser I'm a
perfectionist I'm often on my phone when
you're talking to me I'm passive
aggressive I'm inflexible I have anger
issues and I suffer from a victim
mentality that doesn't sound that bad
oh man that doesn't sound that bad once
you hear links what about the linkster
the link is uh attention seeking overly
competitive he's judgmental he loves to
instigate drama and gossip he loves to
compare himself to others he's jealous
he holds grudges but on top of all that
he is a manipulative narcissist you guys
stuck with both manipulative and
narcissism and you had a choice not to
choose it but you did a double whammy
but I'm going through so much
no you don't even get that I'm the
victim
I'm the victim
okay so uh that was fun though I like
the pace of that one yeah it was it was
so fun we moved we we moved through a
lot do you have a rack to shut this one
I do I have a um
as is somewhat typical from my Rex from
time to time a niche cooking product
that will only make sense or appeal to
less than four percent of you so to
those of you who are in this four
percent listen up I'm about to change
things for you I recently discovered
the little Contraption known as a fat
separator
and I used it uh
to great effect
in my barbecue that I made for you and
friends on the fourth fat separator uh
yeah I got this from another Rec meat
church this is so weird because the one
thing I was going to tell you about that
barbecue is I wish it was fattier
uh
uh well it wasn't fat separator
well it that that didn't have anything
to do with it so it was just us I mean I
guess it was a little bit leaner like
when I when I started pulling it apart I
was like oh wow there's not there wasn't
any fat in it there was not as much it's
just you know sometimes you get one
that's not as fatty but
uh you're talking about like pieces of
fat that you could see yeah yeah well a
lot of times it renders away but what a
fat separator does
is so
what I used to do and the reason I don't
do this anymore is because of what
happens to the leftovers I used to take
it off the grill
and I would uh leave it in all uh
everything that had just rendered all
the fat that it just rendered and I S
and I just pulled the pork together and
just left it all sitting together
what ends up happening first of all most
people don't prefer that most people
want just the just the pork and the
second thing that happens is as you
begin to you know it's out for a while
where you're where you're serving
everybody and then the fat begins to
congeal as it gets to room temperature
and then you've got this fatty thing at
the bottom and then you try to store it
and it becomes really difficult to
convince yourself do you want to eat it
later so what uh uh Matt I guess his
name at me Church
to use the barbecue guy that I get so
many of my recipes from
uh he takes Once you pull it off and you
pull it you pour
the well actually you pull the the pork
out and you separate on a different
thing and then what's left in there is
the arju but it's got all this fat
rendered in it you put it in this fat
separator which is this basically this
cup that has a siphon well has this
anyway it lets you if you sit it out the
fat Rises to the top and there's a big
layer of fat and then there's just the
au jus which is the juice from the meat
and then when you pour it out the spouts
on the bottom so you just pour the auju
back onto the meat without having to
pour all the fat back onto the meat okay
and that stuff is like the best barbecue
sauce you've ever had in your life and
last night I took the auju that was
still in the fridge and I just took like
a couple of spoonfuls on it put it on
some pork warmed it up and like that
pork didn't have any of that like yield
fat on it in the bag and it knows you
didn't and it was so good man so I I'm
assuming the fat separating there's
other applications for this that I'm
only just discovering but if you're
basting or baking or roasting some piece
of meat and you want to get the fat out
of the juice get a fat separator it
would be a game changer for you hashtag
your biscuits one eight eight eight
earpod one that was fun A Rhett and Link
this is Kelsey I'm currently on a eight
hour road trip relocating from
Mississippi to Florida and have just
been listening to episode after episode
of uh ear biscuit episode that I have
been backed up on and I just finished
listening to Link's embarrassing ski
strip story it is one of the reasons why
I love y'all so much it's so
well-rounded and comedy and real
relationships so thank you bye
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
foreign
[Music]